what was your immediate response when
you saw uh the mail on sunday article
well i said it's a great sadness and
obviously you know you can't distract uh
politicians or indeed journalists by
doing it i mean it's farcical isn't yeah
and i think it's great sadness that i'm
just not surprised because this sort of
sexism and misogyny it is frankly the
sort of rubbish that female mps but also
female staffers in the house of commons
have to put up with every single day and
you know when i hear a minister just now
say i haven't heard this sort of thing
before talk to your female colleagues
talk to the women who work in your
office because a lot of them would have
experienced this sort of thing
what then needs to happen next i asked
the minister this morning and frankly
he's perhaps not senior enough to
perhaps be privy to these discussions
but i did ask the minister whether or
not given that given the tone of the
article given the tone of the comments
that we must presume have been made by
by several conservatives that there
shouldn't be some form of internal
investigation
yeah i mean i think that too many people
think this sort of thing is just
acceptable so it's got to be called out
and right from the top and it's got to
be seen as
totally socially unacceptable to be
saying this sort of stuff but you know
there are just too many stories and not
just of of sexism but you know also
things like we've got a conservative mp
in wakefield who's been convicted
of sexual offenses against a child he's
still a member upon when he hasn't had
it in his resignation uh yet you know
we've got to sort out parliament so that
the vetting system of who can be an mp
is improved uh the the processes within
parties improve but also
to make parliament more welcoming for
people including women and women have
been in parliament now for over a
hundred years but still only a third of
mps are women and this sort of rubbish
that angela has been subjected to but
many others as well frankly puts off
good people from putting themselves
forward to parliament and we don't want
that i i certainly don't want this to be
the totality of what we discussed this
morning but one of the curiosities i
just want to show you in the screen of
the way in which the government has
responded to all of this are a couple of
tweets and we put this to chris philp a
little bit earlier here's what the prime
minister uh originally tweeted and if
you can pop it in the screen for us
there we go disagree with angela rainer
on almost every political issue respect
her as a parliamentarian and deplore the
misogyny directed actor anonymously
today and then we heard this
from the culture secretary which if you
squint
is pretty much exactly the same
we understand that boris johnson has
reached out privately to angela raynor
but i wonder what you think this says
about their commitment to sorting this
issue out well this shouldn't just be a
line to take this should be actually
what you feel and what you believe and
also we need some action not just warm
words so the conservative mps have been
briefing journalists this story
need to be made clear to them that this
is totally unacceptable and you know the
conservative mp caroline knox so i've
got huge respect for is calling this out
but is also talking about the culture
that she experiences in parliament
and i think that working together across
the political spectrum we need to do
much more to root out this sort of
behavior as i said i don't want to stay
on this but just just to be absolutely
clear do you think there is a place for
some form of disciplinary action for
those who are responsible for the
briefing well the problem is is we don't
know the names because they don't have
the guts to say this in public they
anonymously brief their friends uh in
the in the press but uh they shouldn't
hide behind that anonymity if that's
what they think have the guts to say it
just to work from you then on what we've
seen across the channel in the past 24
hours emmanuel macron has defeated and
by a margin uh marine le pen who has you
know uh has has acted to soften some of
the more liberal policies that that her
party puts forward but is still broadly
seen as from the far right how concerned
are you
that two in five uh french people who
went to the polls supported her
well it is nice to have some good news
in global politics that the far right in
france have been defeated but no one
should be
relaxed or sanguine about the results as
you say 42 percent of people voted for a
candidate of the uh the far right and
more is needed not just in france but
around the world to tackle some of this
extreme extremism that we see in
politics today from the u.s to france to
sadly britain and beyond i mean there
are there are any number of course of
the places in europe which are also
similarly seeing a rise in far-right
politics i mean is is this what the the
next part of the 21st century is going
to be like a battle against some fairly
illiberal extremist policies i think we
need to take on the the the far right
and uh um marine le pen can uh change
her party's uh name and uh and and try
and put a a a a smile on the far uh
right policies that she espouses but uh
it is uh it is still far right and we
need to to call them out uh for for what
those policies are let's let's talk
about on your brief and
non-dumb status the labour party has
settled on a position let's just hear
what exactly it is if you make britain
your home you should pay your taxes here
that is more than important than ever
because at the moment we are in a cost
of living crisis everybody is noticing
those rising prices and yet at the same
time the conservative party is
increasing taxes on working people and
on the businesses that employ them and
so it is absolutely right that loopholes
are closed down that mean that there are
a privileged few who are getting out of
paying their fair share of taxes these
rules on non-doms are from 200 years ago
they are outdated they are unjustifiable
and unfair and with labour they would go
when you say they would go you you you
do concede i think in the in the press
release that i read that there are a
handful there are small number of cases
in which non-dom status is pertinent is
appropriate so how do you limit it i
mean there appears to be talk of some
kind of time limitation on it so we
would abolish non-dom status but like in
other um modern economies we would have
rules for people who are temporarily in
the uk for a short period of time in
germany and in canada that is six months
in japan it is five years we will work
with business for getting the
appropriate period of time but in the uk
you can be here for year after year
after year
it's time limited to 15. 15. if you live
in the uk for 15 years you should be
paying your taxes here 75 000 people in
the uk are registered for uh non-dom
status uh 2 000 of them have been in the
uk for more than seven years it isn't
right that those people can pay a
one-off fee and get out of paying their
fair share of taxes and so of course we
need to have rules of people who come
here to work on a secondment etc for a
short period of time but if you make
britain your home you should pay your
taxes here like everybody else um so
just in terms of of the time limitation
on this status obviously as you say
you're going to take soundings from
business but it's going to be somewhere
between six months and five years i
would suspect i mean personally where do
you feel is an appropriate place to be
today
i want to consult to get that right but
i've looked at what other countries do
in the u.s you pay full taxes from day
one and no one would suggest that the
u.s is not welcoming of of investment
and entrepreneurs etc so we've got these
different schemes in different countries
we'll consult to get that right but i'm
very clear that the non-dom status that
exists today will not exist with a
labour government we want to ensure that
people feel welcome to come here to to
do a job and to contribute to the
british economy
but that non-dom status where people who
make their home here aren't paying their
taxes that is an outdated concept from
200 years ago and it shouldn't stand
today especially when working people are
seeing their taxes go up and up and up
rachel reeves lovely to see you this
morning thanks for joining us